[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale et régionale tout de
suite les titres de ce jeudi 16 mai une
grande journée pour mettre en avant
l'innovation spring se déroulait hier
sur le campus de l'école centrale
supélec deuxième édition de cet
événement proposé par le pea paris
saclay l'établissement public
d'aménagement dont fait partie saint
quentin en yvelines 2 yvelinoise bientôt
en amérique latine pour une aventure
solidaire sakina alain et natacha
grzeskowiak partiront en octobre pour un
rallye et un trek dans le désert
argentin
elle récolte actuellement des fonds pour
financer des projets humanitaires sur
place nous en parlons en plateau et puis
suite et fin de notre focus sur le
football féminin dans les yvelines après
un état des lieux de la pratique place
ce soir au t1 rencontre avec océane le
cerphi censier à trappes
à 13 ans elle évolue déjà avec des
joueuses plus âgés et rêve d'un avenir
professionnel dans le sport
cette information pour débuter pas de
comportements déviants de la part des
policiers lors de l'interpellation des
lycéens à mantes-la-jolie conclusions de
l'enquêté administrative de l'inspection
générale de la police nationale révélé
aujourd'hui en décembre la vidéo de
l'arrestation de ces 152 jeunes en marge
d'une manifestation avait
particulièrement choqué une quarantaine
de familles et des associations porter
plainte elle dénonce des violences
violations de libertés individuelles et
insultes à caractère raciste
une enquête préliminaire elle est
toujours en cours avec le début de
l'audition des lycéens en début de
semaine c'est un événement mondial
autour de l'innovation le salon vive
attaque a ouvert ses portes aujourd'hui
à paris m ais je vous en parlais dans
les titres en marge de ce rendez vous le
pea paris saclay a organisé à lui sa
propre journée consacrée aux innovations
et aux start up la présence notamment
d'entreprises saint quentinois sur place
le reportage de nicolas d'andré une
solution de livraison à domicile en
l'absence du client voici la freedombox
un frigo stocké à l'extérieur de chez
soi fonctionnant à l'énergie solaire
objectif recevoir ces produits frais
commander sur internet est directement à
son domicile
j'ai commencé les premiers croquis de la
freebox en 2015 et son évolution
développement les boîtiers électroniques
et l'ensemble de la partie intelligence
artificielle et blocs chaîne va être
arrivé progressivement les précommandes
sont déjà disponibles pour une livraison
en juillet 2000 vingt cinq mille fridge
box devraient être produites pour un
coût total de 4 millions d'euros
eric et bill est actuellement en levée
de fonds et cherche de potentiels
partenaires
c'est super activités et pourquoi pas ce
que ça se position sur des secteurs et
sur des domaines qui sont très
d'actualité aujourd'hui à savoir
l'économie circulaire le développement
durable je pense que on a besoin de plus
en plus de projets dans ce domaine des
start up des chercheurs des grands
groupes les acteurs de l'innovation de
paris saclay ont participé à cette
deuxième édition de spring avec une
complémentarité entre les territoires
composant le cluster vous avez saint
quentin qui est le pôle économiques
saclay qui est le pôle plutôt
scientifique et versailles qui est
plutôt le pôle culturel donc ces trois
pôles ces trois agglomérations
travailler ensemble pour préparer la
france de demain dans les secteurs les
plus concurrentiels donc voilà pourquoi
on il aujourd'hui la journée de
découverte des innovations s'est
poursuivie à elancourt sur le site
d'airbus
le thème de la visite la cyber sécurité
présentation des enjeux des menaces et
des outils technologiques comme la sib
orange une plateforme d'entraînement
face à des cyber-attaques l'avenir pas
attaquer le serveur qui est ici et
récupérer tous les utilisateurs qui sont
dans ce serveur est tenté de casser le
mot de passe qui sont un peu faibles
c'est très intéressant pour nous de
rencontrer des partenaires potentiels
divers aussi bien académique des écoles
d'ingénieurs que des pme des start up et
ce exactement l'objet de spring qui elle
en particulier ici à saint quentin en
yvelines et sur paris saclay où il ya un
vrai dynamisme autour de la
cybersécurité et la digitalisation grâce
à la protection de ses clients et à sa
capacité d'innovation airbus
cybersécurité connaît de bons résultats
économiques le groupe a réalisé une
croissance de 30% de son chiffre
d'affaires en 2010 8 le politique locale
avec un changement de plus au sein du
conseil municipal de trappes à un an des
élections dans la commune l'ancien
maire-adjoint conseiller samuel abu
quitte la majorité pour rejoindre le
groupe d'opposition est trappe citoyens
mené par l'élu
républicain othman nassr ou une décision
qui prendra effet au prochain conseil
municipal de la ville programmé le 21
mai c'est une défection de plus pour le
maire guy malandain le mois dernier
l'ancien membre de la majorité gérald
moniot avait déjà rallié l'opposition en
mars et luc de vern qui avait décidé lui
de siéger comme conseiller indépendant
un scrutin national pour désigner vos
députés au parlement de bruxelles et
strasbourg les élections européennes se
tiennent le dimanche 26 mai en france
al'approche de cette date focus sur les
candidats nous posons trois questions ce
soir à mounir à satory qui est en
septième position sur la liste europe
écologie
c'est au micro de mélanie poker voter
pour la liste europe écologie les verts
il mené par yannick jadot
c'est met un bulletin vert pour élire un
député vert qui ira siéger au groupe
verts au parlement européen pour
l'immobiliser les moyens de l'europe
contre le réchauffement climatique
c'est un grand plan d'investissement de
100 milliards par an pour assurer la
transition écologique voter pour la
liste europe écologie les verts c'est
voter pour la possibilité d'adopter des
secondes à un grand traité
environnementale qui met la question
environnementale écologique ou dessus de
toutes les autres pour être à la hauteur
de l'enjeu du réchauffement climatique
voter pour la liste europe écologie les
verts c'est voter pour réconcilier les
femmes - et la fin du monde
[Musique]
l'urgence est telle que il ne sera pas
possible d'agir efficacement à 60
millions d'habitants
nous avons besoin de l'espace européen
pour agir efficacement contre le
réchauffement climatique pour mobiliser
tous les moyens qui nous permettent de
sortir à la fois du nucléaire et des
énergies fossiles à 350 millions de
citoyens engagés à 350 millions de
consommateurs engagés nous pouvons
inverser la tendance et réussir le plus
grand défi qui est de préserver cette
planète en bon état de préserver la
biodiversité et d'offrir un avenir à nos
jeunes nous souhaitons demain au sein du
parlement européen que le groupe le plus
important des les coder les écologistes
participent à imposer la sortie
immédiate du club dit glyphosate et plus
généralement nous souhaitons une
agriculture qui se passe des pesticides
parce que l'agriculture c'est notre
alimentation et parce que nous avons
droit à une alimentation saine sans
pivot hâte parce que la politique
agricole commune c'est le budget le plus
important de l'union européenne c'est
40% mer pour la france c'est 9 milliards
ces 9 milliards doit participer à la
conversion de l'agriculture qui a nous
permettent de nourrir de manière celle à
offrir des revenus décents aux
agriculteurs et à préserver leur santé
en réalité
en réalité la sortie du glyphosate et
des pesticides est bon pour les
agriculteurs bon pour la biodiversité
bon pour les citoyens il nous filmons
que la volonté politique pour y arriver
[Musique]
et pour ce scrutin 34 listes sont
candidates parmi elles on retrouve des
formations politiques historiques
d'autres sont moins connus comme les
oubliés de l'europe une candidature pour
mettre en lumière la voie des artisans
commerçants et des professions libérales
et indépendantes trois questions posées
cette fois-ci par michael et demi
d'euros
[Musique]
les oubliés de l'europe c'est vous c'est
nous c'est les artisans les commerçants
les professions libérales et les
indépendants les auto-entrepreneurs les
intermittents du spectacle mais c'est
aussi les retraités les retraités de ces
professions qui n'ont pas compté leurs
heures pendant toute leur carrière qui
faisait de longues journées qui se
levait très tôt qui se couchait très
tard qui avait très peu de vacances peu
de week-end peu de soirée toujours
présent pour répondre aux demandes de
leurs clients pour former les jeunes au
niveau de l'apprentissage et surtout
transmettre transmettent leur savoir
faire aux jeunes générations
nous au niveau des oubliés de l'europe
nous avons surtout décidé de communiquer
via les réseaux sociaux et internet
nous avons mis en place donc une page
facebook un compte instagram un compte
twitter
les bulletins de vote sont aussi
disponibles sur notre site internet pour
ceux qui veulent imprimer et penser
justement aux économies environnementale
et au respect de l'environnement
moins de papier c'est aussi mieux pour
nous tous au niveau 1
[Musique]
nous sommes les oubliés de l'europe
puisque nous faisons partie des 90 % de
ceux qui font l'économie nationale mais
malheureusement c'est les 10 % qui
restent qui décident de toutes les lois
européennes de toutes les directives de
toutes les normes donc les 90% sont
totalement oubliés et nous sommes tous
oublier les axes forts pour voter pour
les oubliés de l'europe
c'est justement le défendre ces
professions les artisans les commerçants
les professions libérales et les
indépendants nous intervenons auprès des
jeunes pour les former au niveau
d'apprentissage
nous sommes là pour payer les taxes
justement mettre en application les
normes et les directives européennes
toutes ces directives qui
malheureusement font disparaître de
savoir-faire notre savoir faire national
et régional nous cherchons à justement
participer à ces élections européennes
pour faire partie vraiment de ces
nouvelles directives les électeurs sont
demandeurs de ce type de liste sans
étiquette politique il faut pas
l'oublier il nous ne sommes rattachés à
aucun parti et nous voulons garder notre
indépendance
[Musique]
et vous retrouvez l'ensemble de nos
trois questions aux candidats aux
européennes sur notre site internet tv
78 points comme ses collègues le
qualifie de lanceurs d'alert un cheminot
de mantes-la-jolie eric bezou et menacé
de radiation de la sncf ce chef de quai
avait dénoncé un management je cite
toxiques de l'entreprise ferroviaire
l a6 et la direction lui reproche
également de s'être mis à genoux devant
son supérieur depuis ce délégué sud rail
a reçu de nombreux soutiens
une campagne a même été lancé sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag plus
jamais à genoux eric bezeau sera fixé
sur son sort le 23 mai après un conseil
de discipline elle touche environ 15%
des français l'obésité est une maladie
qui est en hausse
responsable de nombreuses complications
physiques et psychiques qui font baisser
l'espérance de vie c'est pour parler de
ce problème que sont organisées les
journées européennes de l'obésité la 10e
édition se tient demain vendredi et
samedi
le thème cette année l'obésité est une
maladie qui se soigne autrement dit
alerter sur la nécessité pour les
personnes concernées est de se faire
suivre par une équipe médicale et à
l'occasion de ces journées européennes
de l'obésité des animations sont
organisées dans les yvelines l'hôpital
de pied de pédiatrie et de rééducation
de bullion présentera son programme
d'éducation thérapeutique
il est destiné aux patients en surpoids
ou obèses banque d'informations demain
la clinique saint louis de poissy de 10h
à 15h venez rencontrer chirurgien
diététiciens psychologues et
l'association de patients des poids
plume
enfin samedi 7 à l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien à trappes entre 10h30
et midi un groupe de paroles réunira
ancien et futur opéré d'une chirurgie de
l'obésité et sachez que le 7-8 l'hebdo
parlera demain vendredi de ces journées
européennes avec en invité la vice
présidente et du cn à eau qui est à
l'origine de ces journées ont clô ture
notre dossier à présent sur le football
féminin avec en ligne de mire cette
coupe du monde qui arrive le 7 juin en
france ce soir direction trappe
le club local compte aujourd'hui plus de
140 joueuses parmi elles parmi elles une
surdouée aussi elle le cerf une jeune
footballeuse qui a été est surclassé de
sa catégorie le portrait signé michael
ennemis dont
océane lecerf 13 ans est l'une des
pépites de l'étoile sportive de trappes
sa passion pour le football a commencé à
l'âge de 5 ans je voulais faire un sport
et je trouvais que ce sport me
correspondait bien j'aime bien jouer au
ballon et j'aime bien courir après avoir
foulé la pelouse avec les garçons à ses
débuts la jeune trappistes joue
aujourd'hui avec les filles et a été
surclassé chez les moins de 16 ans ses
entraîneurs l'ont installé au poste
d'attaquante un choix payant
daniel a marqué notre championnat
comptera plus de dix minutes
elle est vraiment doué techniquement et
spécialiste des passements de jambes la
jeune trappistes fans du psg est
également assidus aux entraînements
sportifs jouent quatre fois par semaine
et n'a jamais manqué une seule session
depuis sa première inscription
ces dernières étaient plâtrés elle est
quand même nos entraînements elle a
suivi toutes les filles au match au
sahel est parti né voir avec elle je
vais pas après l'arrêté non parce que ça
des qualités qui lui permettront
peut-être d'accomplir ses rêves et de
devenir professionnel comme ses idoles
marie laure délie ou qu'il vienne m bape
et j'imagine que je suis apte à quand
j'ai numéro 9 où l humour d'attaqué
voilà et aussi de finir mais avant de
viser plus haut celle veut avant tout
marqué l'histoire de trappes la ville de
son coeur et de ses débuts et après une
pépite football aux rencontres à présent
avec trois athlètes de la gemme
elancourt maurepas elle s'apprête à
participer aux championnats de france de
gymnastique l'événement est programmé du
24 au 26 mai au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
le reportage une nouvelle fois de
michael elle ni d'euros elles sont
revenus tout les trois médaillés des
championnats de france individuels le 12
mai dernier à nice 17 ans ailier et
hyaline 14 ans sont trois gymnastes
yvelinoise formé à l'asm elancourt mort
pas un club qui les a vu éclore les
filles qui ont beaucoup de talent
on essaye dans la mesure du possible de
développer encore plus ses talents mais
pour faire ce qu'elles font il ya il ya
des qualités innées même avec du travail
on pas les avoir ça fait presque 20 ans
que j'entraîne
j'ai vu passer pas mal de gymnastes et
des gymnastes avec autant de talent
aussi bien physiques mentales
il n'a pas beaucoup pour continuer à
progresser les trois pépites qui sont au
club depuis plusieurs saisons
s'entraînent entre 12 et 20 heures par
semaine sur ces à gré aux gymnases du
bois à maurepas et tout cela dans un
esprit familial la politique du club
je pense que ça joue parce que quand
quelqu'un enfin quand par exemple
savamment bien sûr une séance à sont là
pour me motiver ou m'encourager
moi pareil c'est le serpent d'inception
ces retrouvailles défi quand même pas va
enfin en amont envie de s'entraîner du
coup à prendre progressivement
un esprit familial qui est associé à
l'exigence du haut niveau objectif pour
les coaches repousser toujours plus
leurs limites au niveau l'action des
hanches haut niveau l'action des épaules
c'est encore tout petit elles peuvent
encore faire mieux peuvent durcir les
mouvements faire des mouvements on va
dire plus compliqué et plus long plus
propre site
c'est une des qualités de la gymnastique
c'est le côté artistique donc il faut de
l'exécution parfaite si on veut voir des
bonnes notes et donc que des médailles
prochain rendez vous pour ces pépites
les championnats de france par équipes
qui seront organisées du 24 au 26 mai au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
les trois amis auront à coeur de
remporter des titres devant leur public
et mes invités de ce journal m'ont
rejoint emplettes il s'agit de natacha
grzeskowiak et de sakina l'un bonsoir
mesdames vous êtes toutes les deux amis
respectivement trésorière
vice-présidente de grain de sel et vous
allez partir très prochainement pour
l'argentine
c'est du 18 au 31 octobre au programme
de votre séjour notamment un rallye en
4/4 trek et rencontres avec les
populations locales alors c'est une
aventure bien sûr que vous allez vivre
et mais il ya un côté solidaire c'est ça
tout à fait en fait on va vraiment à la
rencontre d'une communauté en
particulier
qui est qui regroupe après 46 familles
donc c'est une grosse communauté qui est
isolée tout en haut à 3000 m d'altitude
des canyon et on va vraiment leur
apporter on aimerait en tout cas leur
apporter des fonds pour développer deux
projets en particulier qu'on a identifié
avec eux qui ont que présentera tout à
l'heure pour quoi ça vous tenait à coeur
de participer à et de faire ce projet de
le mener à bien
je pense que c'est assez motivés par
l'envié de voyager différemment d'abord
tousser
c'est ce qu'il ya c'est ce qui a primé
et puis ensuite on
on est assez sportif donc son côté
aventure et sport c'est quelque chose
qui nous tient beaucoup à coeur et être
au plus près des populations surtout et
vous étiez venu présenter ce projet
alors c'était un projet un petit peu
différent dans l'émission le cetud sport
vous parliez de votre possible
participation au trophée roses des andes
en argentier vous avez choisi finalement
de faire cette aventure vous même sans
partir par un organisme de rallye
pourquoi ce choix final pourquoi changer
de stratégie déjà au niveau des dates
leur a dit venez un peu tôt c'est en
avril c'était un homme est donc là en
fait on serait déjà parti
on avait besoin de récolter quand même
une somme considérable qu'on n'a pas
réussi à récolter à temps et surtout par
rapport à vous voulez vraiment quelque
chose en adéquation avec nos valeurs et
là on organise tout par nous-mêmes et on
fait vraiment comme on l'entend sur
l'ensemble du voyage
on est en simuler des besoins près la
communauté qui nous ressemble et des
choses qu'on est en mesure d'apporter en
fait des solutions auxquelles on peut
on peut contribuer et comment a germé
l'idée de ce projet du coup vous aviez
dit des valeurs communes des idées en
commun à mettre en pratique de ça c'est
ça qui n'a fait quand même à
l'initiative et et par rapport à ce
qu'on va proposer c'est surtout elle qui
porte les idées ouais puis sa patte en
germes et ça a été un peu d'un commun
accord on s'est lancé assez rapidement
dans dans l' aventure déjà dans le
trophée reste des andes à la base on n'a
pas beaucoup réfléchi avant de se dire
allez c'est parti
j'ai présenté comme une évidence mais
voilà plus tôt et puis ensuite le côté
solidaire moi c'est quelque chose qui
m'a qu'elle a toujours été important
pour moi et puis petit à petit natacha
elle a fait son petit bout de chemin de
son côté et ça c'est rejoint ça a été
assez naturel comme c'est vrai que
personnellement je vais un déclic
l'année dernière je suis parti avec la
fondation edf en à madagascar j'ai fait
une mission de 15 jours mais là c'était
organisé
je me suis senti utile enfin voilà pas
de doute là dessus
mais là j'avais vraiment envie
d'organiser quelque chose qui me
ressemble quoi avec une amie super mais
de ma propre initiative
alors votre aventure sur place vous
partez dans le nord-ouest de l'argentine
dans la province de salta
c'est une zone désertique et qui est
particulièrement en altitude quel va
être le programme sur place et ben va
commencer par
on va parcourir toutes les régions donc
on ça va être parsemé de journée en 4 4
donc nous on va traverser des superbes
paysages enfin en tout cas on imagine
et puis et puis des treks à pied des
journées de trek dormir à la belle
étoile en tant qu voilà vraiment de
manière très très rustique accompagné
néanmoins par par un local pour quoique
voilà tout à fait qui a l'habitude de la
région qui organise beaucoup de deux
circuits la rue de l'adapter à notre
demande il ya la rencontre avec la
population locale et ses projets dont
vous parliez en début d'émission en
début d'interview sais c'est quoi du
coup ces projets qu'elles vont être ses
projets la rencontre avec la communauté
c'est vraiment le point final l'objectif
du voyage là bas c'est à peu près deux
jours et deux nuits chez eux donc nous
accueille et nous on veut vraiment leur
apporter nos compétences qu'on sait
faire
donc il ya plusieurs choses au départ on
était parti sur des commentaires de les
former aux gestes de premiers secours
ont ça pour les adultes pour les enfants
plus tôt les ouvrir sur une culture qui
connaissent pas forcément et on a
identifié fin ils nous ont fait part des
besoins bien spécifiques ou là on
apporte pas des compétences mais plutôt
des fonds et on espère avoir assez de
fonds pour pouvoir les aider sur ces
deux projets là qui sont dehors de
l'hygiène voilà il ya une grande
nécessité en termes de salles d'eau il
manque vraiment de de pouvoir se laver
en fait tous les jours et simplement des
chaussures pour aller à l'école aussi
donc c'est des choses qu'on aimerait
leur apporter et puis vraiment on
on se positionne vraiment sur un échange
de compétences
entre eux et nous voilà pas tant à
porter de cas porteurs de fond et voilà
c'est vraiment un échec il ya forcément
aussi ces fonds pour mener à bien ses
projets alors pour récolter ces fonds
vous organiser quelques animations
notamment ce samedi un car wash
solidaire organisé au garage mais
cassure de coignières c'est de 10h à 18h
lors des 10 euros pour la bonne cause
pour ce quart ouest on pourra aussi
faire changer ces plaquettes et disques
de freins elle a aussi une partie est
reversée pour votre action
voilà il y à toutes ces animations ça
c'est important pour pour financer aussi
ce projet oui et surtout en ce projet
c'est quelque chose aussi qui est
familiale fin on a entouré de deux de
nos proches et tout ce qu'on fait on on
veut que ça se passe bien c'est comment
dire c'est des actions qui nous font
plaisir
donc on a organisé des stages de danse
on a fait une chasse une chasse aux
oeufs pour pâques et c'est vraiment des
actions qui demande beaucoup quand même
d'investissement pour peu de bénéfice de
recettes mais ça fait aussi partie de
l'aventuré vous avez besoin de 2 combien
pour pour financer ce projet est mené 6
7 euros
d'accord il ya une cagnotte en ligne
aussi on peut vous aider en ligne
d'ailleurs les instructions s'affiche en
bas de l'écran une petite dernière
question pour finir cet entretien on
peut vous souhaiter quoi en vue de ce
voyage des 6-10 6 octobre
du coup dalbos bonne route et surtout
qu'on est des étoiles plein les yeux là
bas et qu'on puisse être utile et cette
aventure elle se déroulera donc en
octobre n'oubliez pas ce rendez vous un
pour aider natacha et sakina dans leurs
projets ce car wash solidaire qui se
déroule ce samedi c'est de 10 heures à
18 heures au garage mais cassure à
coignières merci à vous deux natacha
grzeskowiak et sakina alain toutes les
informations encore sur votre projet à
retrouver sur le lien qui s'est affichée
durant cet entretien pour clôturer ce
journal rock en seine vous connaissez
forcément ce festival de musique
l'édition à 2019 se déroule du 23 au 25
août à saint cloud est depuis trois ans
le tremplin première scène permet à sept
groupes de jeunes franciliens de se
produire aux côtés des grands de la
sic pour les yvelines la sélection s'est
tenu le week-end dernier c'était à
l'usiné à chapeaux à rambouillet le
reportage de mélanie poker éviter comme
l'aimé à gaza qui il était là pour
prendre du plaisir l'abbé drôme ces
trois jeunes âgés de 16 à 18 ans un
groupe passionné de rap français et us
du rap actuel
on rappelle en fait surtout dans la cour
du collège on aimait bien quoi et
et puis un jour on était au lycée moi
j'avais arrêté j'avais arrêté c'était
une époque où j'avais fait une pause
dans les cours et je les appelais un
jour et juliette était chauffeur un
groupe et il m'a dit oui de suite
et du coup on a commencé comme ça c'est
gros participer au tremplin franciliens
première scène un concours mais aussi
parfois une première scène pour ces
jeunes groupes
[Musique]
on a toujours été attiré par joue de la
musique devant pas mal de monde vient de
trouver quand on a vu le tremplin sur
les réseaux sociaux font suis dit que
c'était france était plutôt sympa de
participer du jeu pour nous de mettre un
peu challenge avec le groupe et puis
après après vingt pour que notre famille
et puis venir aussi première scène est
destiné aux lycéens franciliens depuis
trois ans rock en seine et la région ile
de france donne leur chance à la
jeunesse
c'est une opportunité pour des gens qui
aiment la musique qu'on monte un groupe
de voir ce que ça peut être finalement
que qu'un festival que jouer dans des
conditions professionnelles parce que ce
sera leur premier cachet et puis on va
leur apprendre cet été est ce que c'est
une feuille technique du bac la voilà
des mots qui peuvent paraître un petit
peu technique mais c'est une approche en
douceur
les sélections se déroule sur cette
scène ouverte francilienne depuis le
mois de mars
en attendant pour les vainqueurs de
jouer en août en live un rock en seine
et à l'usiné à chapeaux de renvoyer le
tremplin été remporté par le groupe
halfpipe
c'est la fin du à 7,8 journal replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 dans un instant en fait le
plein d'idées de sorties pour ce week
end dans l'émission le 7-8 loisirs s'est
présentée par marylène yapi chine aux
belles soirées sur tv 78
[Musique]